all right let's go back to the phones at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's talk to let's talk to
Andrey K from Los Angeles what's going
on today hey David how's it going man
good how are you okay thanks so again
thanks querida man you're amazing
hold on a couple of things this time
yeah number one I think I think what
Trump is doing at the border is totally
on purpose and it's a distraction and I
think this was just a like a big plan
I'm doing all this crazy stuff so that
Democrats go and do what we always do
and go crazy and you know do what the
squad's doing and you know I'll go on TV
and talk about the horrible things that
are happening yeah I really being Trump
is not intelligent like when it comes to
policy reading and all that stuff but he
is really good I like sales and
manipulation and all that so I really
think that we need to be against what
he's doing but we need to talk about
like the issues that the vast majority
of Americans are worried about because I
think that it's a huge distraction it
really is and I'm a static American
myself yep it's a huge distraction and
and words and it's it's incredible
number two I think that let me talk
about that I mean there's a lot there
Enrique that I want to address I think
you're basically correct what you
pointed out that's really important is
when we say something is a distraction
by Trump we don't mean that it doesn't
matter right so as you're pointing out
right from doing that the border is
disgusting it's really affecting
people's lives it's affecting American
lives it's affecting a lot the lives of
people from other countries it's
disgusting and an absolute disaster and
he's a total ignoramus when it comes to
policy and we should be opposed to what
he's doing at the same time we should
make sure that our reactions don't give
him a win by number one you're dividing
the left in ways that are
counterproductive number two we're
getting his actual other scandals out of
the the new cycle so as an example over
the weekend when he said you know the
four
Congresswomen need to go back to their
original countries it made it so there
was no coverage over the weekend of the
growing links between Trump and Jeffrey
Epstein who's been accused of serial
child sex trafficking and all the other
stuff so you're you're astutely pointing
out just because it's a distraction
which Trump is good at doesn't mean that
what he's doing doesn't require our
opposition it does but we need to be
thoughtful in how we oppose it yeah and
that's why I think like the top
leadership like Pelosi she's you know
she's skilled and she's a she's a master
politician herself that's why she
doesn't go all crazy like ALC and you
know which I think what's going on is
horrible but I think that they should
just say look this is a horrible issue
and we need to deal with it the way like
just we need to set it to default like
this is America we have standards there
are no human rights violations here and
we're gonna deal with it that way end of
story you know you should not allow
human right you're not saying that there
aren't any going on you're saying they
were going on and we all know you
shouldn't allow it got it yeah yeah yeah
and that's it but that's basic we've
already done with that that's an old
thing America just doesn't do this right
and let's move on yeah right number two
I think that what's happening with Trump
I think is really dangerous I think it
is very scary and this is gonna sound
crazy but when Obama got elected Inouye
I was really worried because the way my
mind works really I'm not getting like I
told my brother my politics all the time
and I said you know what this is bad he
was like why this is grails like yeah I
know it's great but it's it's bad in a
way because it's gonna rile up a lot of
people and a lot of people aren't ready
for this and I think that Trump is just
you know the aftermath of that that's
that's just my opinion I think I think
the country was ready for Barack Obama I
think no matter when we had our first
right you know half black president
there was going to be a group that was
radicalized and activated by that I
think you're right that the timing when
Donald Trump said ham and a run for
president was unfortunate timing but I
think the country was ready for Barack
Obama right right I mean yeah yeah but
it does just mean like I thought like it
was going to cause them back
that's against brown people I like
that's just very basic in my mind I was
like this is gonna hurt from people like
brown Americans and yet I didn't it's
really quick talking about like going
back to the thing about town squares I
always wanted to say something about
that I really don't think that YouTube
is like the town square I don't your
organ was talking about like yeah like
you know freedom of speech I really
don't think it's that way on the
internet because when you have a child
Square meeting with citizens you know
coca-cola is in advertising at that Town
Square sure you know what I mean so
we're meeting you often do have to pre
submit your questions only a certain
number of people get to talk there's a
limited amount of time there's a limited
number of seats so I mean I think that
you're right that using the Town Square
analogy or Town Hall analogy we can find
ways in which there is certainly it's
certainly okay to allow a platform to
have rules I think my biggest concern
now and Enrique I'm gonna wrap after
this because I got a few other people
who talk to you my concern is that
YouTube is not actually enforcing their
own rules in a way that is fair not the
fact that the fact they have rules is
not the problem it's that they're
enforcing them in a way that is very
unfair hey David and one last thing I
think all progressives like you
convinced us you know that you guys
should all unite and create one channel
like Fox yeah there are some
complexities about that but it's an idea
and Rica I appreciate the call great to
hear from you thanks for your time all
right